so I wanna so as we were stating here
this is a wonderfully eclectic
conference the talks have spend almost
everything from the largest skills in
the universe we will be getting some of
the smallest scales yesterday unka
finished off the afternoon telling us
about robotics and human robot
interaction as part of it was dealing
with autonomous driving Jane is going to
tell us today I would say the view is
more from 30,000 feet and and how we
understand traffic and its impacts and
being able to deal with that mobility
Jane and I are currently in a battle
between the Department of Energy la
Metro organizing lemons try to get them
to work together providing free
resources to solve some of these
problems that we hopefully will beer
about today so thank you
well good morning everyone
I dunno it's not July 30th 2017 I
apologize for that I used an old
template for my flight what I'm going to
talk about today is a myriad of things
I'm going to talk about transportation
and the transformation that's going on
in transportation I'm going to talk
about the data that we use in
transportation which includes geospatial
temporal data as well as maps and and
I'm going to just throw out some of the
really interesting challenges of working
in this space for you to think about so
we're all quite aware that we're going
through a significant transformation
which is why half of the room is not
here because we have learned that we
don't need to be in the same room
anymore so it's and and what's happening
is it's really changing how we think
about the world and how we interact in
the world and so what we have is all
these computational tools that are
generating representations of our world
and the like and we are getting big data
on it which allows us to model and
predict we are we've got the Internet of
Things happening which is generating all
kinds of interesting geospatial data and
the networks are getting tremendously
more capable I used to work for OnStar
in year 2000 I was the director of
technology and we couldn't get any of
that data out of the car because there
was no bandwidth the first OnStar
vehicles had analog phones in them
analog radios in them so look at what
has changed in just this period of time
so we have a convergence of IOT
bandwidth and data science all coming
together which is really exciting and
really challenging and also very costly
so there's a lot of interesting aspects
to what's going on right now and these
this this transformation is some people
saying our fundamentally change
the way we live work and relate to each
other and we need to take note so
citizens and social systems are now
interacting through technology
so there's this convergence happening so
what I'm going to talk about is mobility
the movement of people and goods so just
we know this is true but in one minute
this is the kind of information that's
moving now so we've got Google searches
which is capturing where we're wanting
to go it tells us a lot about human
beings and what we're doing which is one
of the challenges in transportation
because we have data about how many
people are on the road but we don't have
much data about why they're on the road
so there's there's that kind of pesky
human problem in the midst of all this
data is that those pesky humans are very
chaotic and we don't know why they're
there and what they're doing that it's
kind of amazing when you look at Amazon
is selling two hundred and sixty five
thousand dollars worth of goods every
minute
and that's probably low now that's
probably an old number which is
fundamentally changing our logistics
systems which I'll talk about later so
unfortunately you can't see this these
are beautiful images you should see them
on my Retina screen of the sea these are
images of geospatial data so this came
from data that we worked with when I
worked at here-here technologies here
technology is a mapping company and they
collect all this data by virtue of
delivering traffic products so that they
can tell us what it looks like that out
there on the road so they're really rich
images they look much better on those
screens if you look at those screens
they're just beautiful they tell us
about the structure of the city they
tell us about where the hot spots are
and lots of interesting information
buried in there their cell phone traces
these are just cell phone traces but
here collects them from fleets and the
light let's go ahead
what are the colors the colors officer
forgive me this is a data science group
blue is fast speed red at slow speeds so
they're colored by speed of of those
devices that are moving they're just
devices so I don't know what kind of
device it is in this picture but we can
separate it out yes
so what we're so we're getting just
massive amounts of geospatial temporal
data via smartphones vehicles IOT
devices and then we are also getting
light our images a lidar and images
these are the things that are being
composed today to make the
next-generation maps so High Definition
maps so high the maps are now changing
from that 2d kind of flat map that we
used to unfold in our car for people my
age younger people don't do that anymore
but they're changing they're changing
into high-definition maps that are
centimeter level accuracy the reason why
they're changing is because the
autonomous vehicle folks are asking for
that level of accuracy for localizing
vehicles so we had all that data and
then we have the challenge of mapping it
to our known representation of the world
so I have to take the GPS data and what
you see here are a GPS data from a
vehicle that we have and we had at here
technologies that has an IMU on it so we
know exactly where that vehicle is that
vehicle is instrumented such that we
couldn't even take that vehicle to China
because it could be taken apart and
turned into a missile and then here is
data inertial measurement unit so exact
it's a it's an exact location a GPS has
maybe a 10 meter resolution right so if
you take we had a cell phone in the
vehicle as well and then what you have
to do is you take that GPS data and you
try to match it to the real world so
that you can know where this vehicle was
that that that phone was and you can see
at doing great right here then all of a
sudden it jumps over here based on the
algorithm that we had and then it
figures it out and I said oh no I'm not
on that road I'm on this road and it
jumps right back
it gets very confused so just the map
matching part can be quite a challenge
I'm sure you have
today's traffic environment and as I
said we've got devices out there picking
up date on like every second do we
really need data every second so there's
a lot of work to be done in compression
intelligent compression so this is a
representation of a part of Auckland
near where I live and I took that data
and I said you know what Shannon's
theory if your folks that are
information press says that you don't
need to sample that offering so you can
use actually the representation of the
map to reduce your sampling period so
then you can start looking at different
areas and saying if I where it's a fleet
manager I can reduce the data that I
have to bring in by understanding where
I am in on a map so there's a lot we can
do to reduce this data that we're
collecting which costs money to collect
archive and process so we need to start
thinking more that more data is not
better information is better which I'm
preaching to the choir here this is an
example of the city in the Netherlands
called Eindhoven where we took this kind
of data
and we look to see where people are
lingering so if you've got all this GPS
trail so you can start finding the hot
spots of the city where do people go to
have coffee where do they go to have
dinner when do they go there so you can
start to learn the dynamics of the city
but there's all kinds of interesting
difficulties with this data and it's not
gonna get better with IOT because when
I'm dealing with that data I don't know
where this data came from I don't know
anything about the device that I got it
from might be a vehicle might be a cell
phone if you ask a carrier what cell
phones are generating this data they
have no idea so the characteristics of
the device itself have to be included in
your understanding of the data now what
we would do is we would source data from
all different kinds of places all
different kinds of fleets phones
navigation devices all kinds of devices
and this is the kind of thing you might
find in it so this is one source out of
hundreds so this is a big data veracity
problem so buried in that one in that
massive data that we're collecting is
this where we've got little collections
of data bunched up here for no apparent
reason I have no idea why that's the way
it is and have no idea what to do with
it you throw it out do use it there's
another example one of the sources
decided to map match it for us very kind
of them but I don't know what map they
matched it to so now their source of
data is a questionable source of data
here's another one they dropped a bit on
the GPS data and gridded it for us thank
you very much but we didn't want to ask
here's a really interesting one in
Russia if you were working in here with
a data set in here you'd have no idea
that this is just wrong
something is very wrong here here's an a
really interesting one where they
actually displaced the data to the wrong
part of the globe right so here are
three different providers of data again
amongst 200 or 300 or how many we have
in this location and this whoops this is
just this is probably good data just put
in the wrong place in the world they
flipped a bit somewhere the red data
looks kind of right but no it's got
these straight lines in it and then the
green data is just junk all buried in
two massive amounts of data that's one
of our challenges I think as we go
forward with any geospatial data
analytics is understanding your data and
the veracity so what this really boils
down to is and I think going forward of
how we're going to operate is we're
moving into geospatially distributed
temporal data analytics that's our
future we can't do this all in one cloud
we can't through it all up to the top
and do some global analytics we're gonna
start doing analytics at various levels
in the ecosystem so we'll have a IOT
devices doing data analytics we'll have
vehicles doing data analytics we'll have
networks towers doing data analytics
we'll have cloud doing data analytics so
that is I believe where we're heading
with this kind of data analytics I just
want to share with you some of the other
pieces that's interesting about mapping
and geospatial data collection because
these maps are going to have a huge part
of the autonomous vehicle
what what what is it that you want to do
with these I want to understand the
mobility I want to understand where
people are hanging out I want to
understand you know how to manage
traffic in a city how do we do better
logistics better faster and you know
this is a really key problem because our
cities are urbanizing right now and
anybody who lives in the city here knows
how bad the traffic is now and it wasn't
that way 10 years ago it's really
changing and they say I think the cost
we have we in the United States have the
three out of the top five congested
cities we have three of them and the
cost to the cities across those three is
like sixty two billion dollars and
productivity cost in in cost of gasoline
and cost of you know there's a variety
of different costs that build up this is
a serious problem for our economy and
it's only going to get worse if we don't
deal with it now and that's the second
part of my talk is to talk about the
transportation issue the first part was
just to give you a sense of what kind of
data we're using to understand
transportation and and to drive some of
the things that we're speaking about
like autonomous vehicles and autonomous
shuttles and things like that so this is
the data piece and then I'll tell you
more about the transportation side one
aspect of provenance of data is
basically ownership of data huge problem
particularly when the objects that are
being represented or public objects like
the public roadways and appends and the
image tunnel that you might get from
driving on a public or public road
Thanks and we see it pop up with with
privacy issues in those image those
with street addresses absolutely and
then that it's it's the up it's both
sides of that is it interferes with the
street address but then there's people
that don't want their street address and
a map Germany that's huge you can get
you in the map companies actually have
to allow people to come in and take
their house out of the map so so they're
sort of proprietary interest that's been
invading what heretofore had been maybe
a scientific or I mean is correct
which is a huge problem that and that's
kind of the second piece is that who
owns the data right because most of the
data that I'm showing you isn't public
it's here is here owns that data Google
owns their data Apple owns their data
but we actually should own our data
that's a whole nother topic yeah may be
connected to that does it safe to assume
that in this kind of horror stories of
data no you know problem it's really
that there's no way to give feedback to
the providers to say can you do better
it's very difficult it's very difficult
because you have to do all the work to
dig it out right so that's I think
there's a whole lot of work to be done
on the data veracity side because we get
excited about collecting all this data
and we get giddy with the with the
thought of what we have and then you
have to really make some sense out of it
and and it goes a little bit too far
over the edge particularly with the
machine learning craze where everybody
feels like you just pour all the data
into the bucket and magic happens in
there and poof none of this matters
anymore right which I will say blatantly
that is not true my my mantra with my
research group was know your data you
have to know your data before you do
anything with it and visualization
becomes a key part of that which is why
we were creating all those beautiful
images so collection vehicles are out
there pulling in images to find those
street addresses and the like we're all
by the way helping them figure out what
the numbers are by filling out your
CAPTCHA when you get you your something
when you log in to Google or whatever
but here's some example of some of the
image analytics from real world is that
you know he underexposed overexposed
this is photo I keep hitting the wrong
button here this is photogrammetry data
so airplanes flying with cameras where
they flew it if they fly at the wrong
time of day the shadows make it very
hard to classify what the image is
telling you and here's the same even
just on a building if you want to
retexturize the side of a building a 3d
building that you're putting on a map
that can be very confusing for the
analytics lidar I mentioned this is
another big craze right now that lets
you pull out building facades curbs
lanes
traffic's signs because it's just
basically lidar reflecting luckily our
our streets have reflective materials on
them but it's huge amounts of data
because it's just a point cloud it's
centimeter accuracy but it's just a
point cloud which means you have to do
lots of analytics to pull out those
features in that massive point cloud and
here is an example of lidar trip and so
we're trying to figure out where the
lanes are so we're doing we were doing
this is when I worked at here a lot of
work to try to take all those pesky
trees out of there and all that noise
out of there in order to find the flat
surfaces and then to look for the lane
markings so that we could understand
where the lanes are so that we can build
that high-definition map that the
autonomous vehicles are working off of
so lots of challenges and then you go
into like the dead space inside the
intersection where you have no help on
where the lanes are as you make the
turns which can be quite complex to
figure
out in large intersections so that's the
data piece the challenges which I'm sure
you're all are seeing we have a lack of
labelled data sets out there for anybody
who wants to do some of the machine
learning associated with this we have
lack of big data for researchers so we
have this membrane between public and
private where researchers aren't getting
this huge data sets that they can work
on so that's actually one of my charters
in the next few years is to make that
membrane more porous so that industry
will let loose some of that data so that
that that we can get you know the
research side moving up a little in the
data analytics opportunity side
otherwise we're going to lose all the
researchers into the Facebook's and
googles of the world privacy as I
mentioned huge problem who owns the data
actually I should own my own data that's
why it used to work in vehicles but now
we are all quick to say I agree okay and
all of a sudden all our data has gone
away
so everybody's collecting it from you
and that which is fair if it's a
value-add if it's a win-win for both
sides but it would be nice if we could
offer our data out things like that we
need to come up with new ways of moving
the data from these devices into places
where we can all operate on the data go
ahead
one of the things that sort of struck me
was that even if I so the Strava heat
map release that happened yes yes you
know even though I may not feel any
particular need to keep private where I
go jogging and cycling and you know none
of you may feel particularly you know
like it's it's okay you know that that
you know you're concerned about the
privacy it's like it's the aggregate of
the and that is actually something that
the current you know sort of definitions
definitions of privacy they don't really
address all right today I mean you know
privacy is always is always aimed at
well you know you have a personal need
desire to keep your data private but in
fact you may not and and none of us may
but but in aggregate it leaks yes no not
at all so maybe with as long as well as
mutual information there's mutual
privacy yeah aggregate aggregate
pregnancy you know but and I you know I
haven't seen anything that addresses
addresses that I thought this drama
thing was fascinating yes that was a big
hole in their security that individual
people could not have done anything
about they could have acted in such a
way well the this is an interesting
conversation which I think we should
continue because I think it was the
organization's fault in that case right
so they I mean if you're a security
officer you know if you're the CSO of
whatever armed forces you say you won't
wear those devices and that was just a
hole in their awareness I think okay
yeah
organizational problem right no it's not
a personal problem correct you know
people may feel differently about this
and that's fine you know as individuals
maybe what we're missing collectively is
the value of the data right if the if
people are not recognizing that in
aggregate the data has financial they
help you yeah yeah then they're not
starting the transaction directly and I
would say that's it there's an
interesting cultural issue going on
right now is it when you get to the
private side everybody thinks their data
is worth its gold it's it's absolute
gold but I keep telling everybody it's
not gold it actually costs you a lot of
money to keep it and it costs you a lot
of mining to to make it worth the gold
so you really only have a few nuggets in
there so you really should work with
other people to help you get the Nuggets
out and then we'd all be happy I was
pretty much suggesting that people could
come together to recognize how to
exactly they could do that first and or
whatever right which is again why I'm
kind of honest on this I don't know I
I'm trying to get awareness across
private that we need to break that
barrier down particularly when it comes
to transportation because transportation
is a public concern it's not a private
concern that's one of the reasons why I
left here is because I can't solve
transportation from a product
perspective we have to solve this from
the top down and it's going to have a
huge impact on our economy if we don't
go after this so this is the
transportation piece of the discussion
we used to think you know Japan they're
all crap and you know stuck in their
subways and you know we expect that
there this is my ride to San Francisco
on BART
recently
and you'll note that he does not look
very happy and neither was I by the way
and this was after I let two trains go
by so I'm I had to I couldn't even
squeeze my body in there or was not
willing to squeeze my body so it's
happening and it's happening in all our
big cities we can't build these like
they have in China there's no room in
our cities to build these and the
Federal Highway says in 2035
approximately 40% of the roadways will
approach or exceed capacity so we are in
a serious transformation in
transportation and by the way
transportation is kind of the unloved
stepchild when it comes to technology
right a lot of the technology on our
roadways is not very new and it's
actually not very sophisticated I could
tell you stories so it again what's key
about this is it affects everybody in
this room and it affects every business
because it's not just communal I keep
doing that sorry it's not just commutes
its freight delivery its supply chain
its product to customer its retention of
employees its productivity of employees
it's a huge problem and again I think
the answer is going to be geospatially
distributed computing because of the
size of the data that's being collected
we can't just push it all up we're gonna
have to really think about how we do
this the vision everything's connected
everything's you know high-tech
everything's gonna be alright but it's
not that way now it absolutely is not
that way now and what's happening in
these ports is the port's used to take
the containers off the ships and they
put them on a railcar and off they would
go to the warehouse that's distributed
that's located somewhere but now because
we want our bottle of Tide soap on our
doorstep the day after we ordered it or
maybe even now two hours after we
ordered it what's happening is they're
springing up all these little mini
warehouses which means these containers
in the shipyard now have to be broken
down into bits and pieces and they have
to be put on single owner small run
trucks that's hugely different than
going onto a railcar to some place in
some city so they're going through a
transportation I mean a transformation
inside just the port's that just gives
you an example of a little tiny piece of
what's happening out there so sort of
going looking backwards in history I
mean the container container based
freight delivery that sort of post-war
phenomenon really worked its own
revolution and could you see this as
well it's a continuation it's good yep
this is this is this is forcing all the
IT systems to have to morph it's causing
cities to get backed up with semis
sitting in lines to get in there because
they can't move the containers around so
yes they're gonna have to completely
reinvent themselves as a result of what
these pesky humans are doing right you
talked about autonomous vehicles I am on
the not so excited about autonomous
vehicle side so I'll just say that
straight up I used to work for OnStar I
care about safety I'm very concerned
about safety there's the belief that
we're just gonna get all this
information buy it from the
transportation system from these
vehicles and pop it up to the cloud and
we'll all know everything that's going
on right now and that's it's just not
feasible not yet
so are they going to grow the chaos or
calm the dynamics they could do both we
can squish more cars on those freeways
actually that there's really interesting
control theory work that shows that you
can throw a autonomous vehicle into a
traffic jam and it will come all the the
dynamics that happens in traffic jams
so they actually can add value but how
do we use them and what can we do with
them because it's a very highly semantic
contextual environment that we're
operating in inside that vehicle the new
vehicles are very excellent at
localization they're uh you know when I
worked at OnStar I was allowed to put a
hundred and twenty-five dollar unit
inside the vehicle that's all I had now
we've got Volvo's that have cameras
completely surrounding the vehicle
they've got lidar they've got amazing
sensors in them today so there's a lot
you can do from a localization point
inside the vehicle this is the I'm
wanting to show you an example of a good
use of automation this is actually my
advisor at the University of Minnesota
where they are using high accuracy GPS
systems to instrument highways in Alaska
so that when they have big snow events
the drivers of the snowplows can drive
the snowplows without visual feedback so
they've got radar they've got high
accuracy GPS this is an excellent
example of a good use of autonomous
automated vehicles and they're using
them today you're using this is actually
a Caltrans video where Caltrans is using
it so this is really exciting now
whether I think it's good on the campus
road out here that's a different story
the vehicle is not a consumer device
and we have to remember that because we
tend to throw consumer devices into
vehicles and think that we can manage a
consume that consumer a vehicle the same
way we can manage a consumer device
vehicles are deadly weapons and we have
to be very considerate about how we put
technology in these vehicles so again on
this on this story is when we drive we
made a lot of judgments we make a lot of
predictions we process scenes and if you
I don't know unfortunately I had the
Department of Energy and yesterday so I
didn't get to see the talk there's a lot
of really interesting work being done
and seeing analytics but we're not there
yet we're not there yet and it's a very
complex stochastic environment this is
not a chair traffic control system this
is not airplanes this is very different
so this is an example of the
high-definition maps that these
autonomous vehicles are using so that
all that lidar is is shown right here
all those lane markings that's the the
product of that data analytics that I
was showing you earlier collected by
vehicles like this the Google vehicles
that are out there and note that way MOA
was out in the snow trying to figure out
whether their autonomous vehicle can
operate in the snow because these
sensors all have edges of technology in
them and so they didn't know how to do
that so they went out there and started
trying to learn so that's where we are
in the real world of autonomous way you
get past the height that's in the in the
literature there's a lot we can learn
this is an example of some connected
vehicle a connected vehicle effort that
was at DIA I think was do team was
running in Michigan where they're
collecting canvas the sensor data off
the vehicle so we can learn a lot about
where people break that can inform how
we want these autonomous vehicles to
work cooperate you can see where people
are slowing down here
speed again sorry for my original lack
of explanation so you can see kind of
where people tend to start to slow down
to allow other vehicles onto the road
you can get a lot of information out of
it for sure to understand how to build
autonomous vehicles better this is an
example of us we were looking at what
what is a good speed to go around this
curve so we took up a bunch of data of
taxis going around that curve and we
found that even though you might be able
to go through that curve faster in your
vehicle there is a there's a g-force
that we as human beings feel fairly
comfortable with so everybody kind of
went to that same speed as they went
through the curve so that tells us a lot
about how we operate on the highways and
we can maybe build vehicles that kind of
operate more like we're kind of that
that we would be comfortable in and this
was just an example of how you know if
you just have the windshield wipers you
can start to localize storms because the
vehicles are all telling you that
there's a storm going on and you could
easily you know if you had connected
vehicles you can communicate back to a
path behind you to let people know time
to slow down because there is a nasty
storm
so regardless of my concerns the world
is moving forward and you know the
autonomous vehicle activity is well on
its way and will happen and already
people are starting to propose
expressways that might just be
autonomous vehicles only nobody really
knows what the answer is right now for
this but what I wanted to kind of put in
the back your mind is for those of you
that looked they are aware of the Tesla
crash that happened in Florida a few
years ago that was an edge of technology
problem it was a white truck against a
very bright sky and he shouldn't have
been driving the vehicle as if it was an
autonomous vehicle this was Tesla's are
not autonomous they just assist and he
just went right underneath the truck and
died this is now there's more coming is
that a Tesla just ran into the back of a
firetruck on a freeway at 65 miles an
hour they survived which is a testimony
to how safe the car hiss but we're
hitting the edges of the technology
already
so well know all this technology do we
have no idea what the impact is going to
be on energy on emissions on we just
don't know and we're learning now and we
need help we need all your help to think
about these things
we've got rideshare coming into cities
uber lifts that are dramatically
changing the traffic profiles I think a
year ago we had 45,000 uber lyft drivers
registered in the city of San Francisco
and if you walk down the city of if you
walk down the streets you will see uber
lyft uber - really
a lot of them with just one person in it
which means they're driving around so
that's a huge issue and we've got of
course the third dimension happening I
don't know if you know but in Dubai
they're already putting in air taxis
station two tation station to station
one person air taxis so we are going
into the third dimension and of course
we can always go to the underground
which is also an option and popular with
mr. musk
so why do we care about this because we
care that we're building urban by our
environments that people want to live in
and if we don't address this problem we
may have cities that nobody enjoys
living in and our emissions will go up
and we won't enjoy what the outcome is
so we need to start looking at
efficiencies at vehicle level system
infrastructure looking at demand why are
there so many people out there our
vehicle miles traveled were three point
two trillion miles in year 2017 which is
the fifth year of increase now the gas
prices are down which is part of the
reason but it's we're just we're just
driving more we're just out more our
populations are higher we're urbanizing
it's all happening so what we need to do
this is the project I'm working on
currently which is a high performance
computing project we need to understand
urban at scale nobody can do this right
now nobody has the data and the models
sometimes take days to run depending on
what you're trying to model so city
planners are working with models that
take days to run and state-of-the-art
models maybe take hours to run so this
is the work we're doing up at Lawrence
Berkeley labs is to try to do urban
scale modeling so one of the things is
we don't have a lot of data so I'm
working with industry to get that probe
data so that we can understand more
about what the dynamics look like we
need to build models for the veracity
veracity you've seen can be a problem
and then fusion of multiple data sources
because the reality is those sensors
that are out there on the roadways they
only work part time somebody comes done
does maintenance and they mess it up or
they put things on the wrong side of the
road all of that happens it's real-world
data we need to reduce the data with
intelligent compression algorithms which
I talked about earlier we are over
sampling the world right now and we need
to build
high-performance computing modeling if
we're gonna get at urban scale dynamics
when I said you can't do this from a
product based perspective this is an
example I always tell the people that
are working on the ramp metering systems
I say who do you think is controlling
all those vehicles out on your freeways
and they say well I've got my ramp
meters right and I said now Google's
driving a high traffic Apple is driving
all that traffic here is driving all
that traffic and they're all taking
different samples of data because
they're using the devices that they have
out there to make decisions about where
they want to send their people and they
are all using different routing
algorithms so this is really a
non-cooperative gaming problem alex is
going to talk about this more in the
next session alex and i work very
closely together so we don't have any
control about what's going on in
everybody's right now because they are
doing it all they have all the data so
what we're trying to do is build this
high-performance computing solution I
clearly have too many slides so I'm
gonna go really quickly now we're gonna
have to learn the patterns out there
we're gonna have to understand what the
drivers if those patterns are and we
have to start thinking about control
ideas on how to move people off those
freeways how to route them better how to
get people not showing up on the
freeways there's a whole lot of work
that needs to be done so we're working
on a project that's taking real-world
data that's coming from a connected
corridor down in Los Angeles so what and
I'll show you what that looks like we're
going to put it into high-performance
computational tools for modeling the
urban scale
so this is the connected corridor I'm
speaking of so this is a quarter of I to
ten in Los Angeles it goes across three
cities so we've got three cities engaged
in managing this we've got street lights
we've got inductive loops that are
giving us flow information we've got
ramp meters we've got all kinds of
things and then we have again those
navigation systems that are moving
everything around as well and this
corridor has like five incidents a day
not good drivers in this part of Los
Angeles so the question is how do you
start to manage this if you have an
incident what do you do where do you
move all these people and if you have
two connected quarters then what do you
do if you move them in the wrong
direction they'll mess up the other
quarter so how do we deal with this
problem so this is a traffic that so
this is the classic traffic assignment
problem and and Alex will talk about
this in the middle in a minute but
basically you have a model of your
network your road network you are
assigning vehicles to their routes on
that road network you get a cost and you
sum up the cost that's the traffic
assignment piece and then you put a
solver in the in the midst and try to
figure out where to put them so that's
the Nash equilibrium solution Alex we'll
talk about that in a minute as I
mentioned what we're doing is we are
putting in trip legs of vehicles going
different places during the day routing
algorithms and what the routing
algorithm penetration might be to kind
of model how those navigation systems
work and then create network disturbance
in order to come out with emergent
behavior and try to understand better
what's going on on the highways so this
is a project that we call mobility and
we're trying to leverage the
supercomputing assets up at Lawrence
Berkeley Lab I'm going to go quickly
through this we're taking advantage of a
lot of the work that's been done already
we took a simulation of
finite element analysis and repurposed
it for traffic which is pretty cool so
now it's an actor based representation a
link on the road network is the actor
and the vehicles travel along the link
and they congest according to a classic
traffic equation about that represents
as I get more vehicles on my link than I
slow down that's how congested is
represented and the link mediates the
congestion the challenge is most the
reason why those modeling systems work
so slowly is because a lot of them use
what we call a conservative parallel
discrete event simulation where there is
a master of the universe for the
simulation everybody calculates where
they're gonna go the shortest distance
everybody goes for chunk and then they
do it again so that doesn't lend itself
at all to high-performance computing you
need distributed mechanisms and which we
call the optimistic parallel discrete
event simulation and how you partition
your network is key to how well this
works and luckily I have one of the
masters of the universe doing that now
and so we are working on a San Francisco
Bay Area model then the road network
itself has 1.1 million notes with 2.2
million links so II wrote a piece of
road is a link and two nodes that's the
road network so that the whole Bay Area
nine-county
is 1.1 million nodes our initial testing
we can run 3.7 million vehicles in their
daily path going from home to work to
lunch to work to home all different
kinds of patterns there we can run 3.7
million agents which turns into 9.5
million leg trips and 2.4 billion
vehicle arrival events we can run that
in a minute so we've gone from days
hours to minutes on the computer at LBL
which means we can now start to really
look at what congestion means in a full
urban scale environment so these are the
top 10,000 congested links in the Bay
Area and it's showing how this is kind
of a delay view of the problem so you
can start to see where things tend to
build up as the day goes on this is
noontime and then you'll see the
congestion come back up when everybody's
on their way home then now since we've
got the dynamics then we can start doing
some work on it this is literally hot
off the press we just did this so we've
got a long way to go yet flow whoops
hello is the vehicles per minute
where where where is where all the
vehicles building up so the last view
was congestion where are you getting
delayed it's a function of the capacity
of the road and now we've got an insight
into where the all the flows are
happening during the day so we're
capturing the dynamics of the entire Bay
Area in a minute
so there you see three o'clock Bay
Bridge starts to build up again four
o'clock it gets worse it's hard to see
because there's red links buried
underneath here it's colored again red
it's low blue is fast but this is the
top 10,000 out of a million so then you
can start looking at trip counts from a
location you can start looking at
distance from a location and then map it
into fuel consumption and then you can
learn more about what's what's the
impact on the energy profile of the Bay
Area and this is kind of a triple an
example for a one kilometer region
during that day so you can start to see
these trips building up with the
distance of those trips via the routing
algorithm I showed on the earlier slide
so then you can start seeing what the
the pressure is on this network because
at the end of the day what are you
looking at optimism how do we get people
to their destination faster okay so not
necessarily say total fuel consumption
oh that's very important no no its
productivity its energy and it's um
there's three of them productivity
energy doesn't know to that I care about
right and then so that's what business
cares about productivity you know what
your employee is sitting on this mess
out here right so and we can't you know
all your delivery trucks that are trying
to bring you your time
so Bunyan on your front doorstep are
sitting in this as well so logistics
people care when you talk about like
standard Network routing you know
there's throughput congestion yeah yeah
medea we very much cares about how much
for you all we are using I guess coming
from from Europe it's astonishing how
many things you can get delivered here
yes are you also trying to congregate
these people so that they have a more
optimized way of doing so because of
course if there's one person bringing
you a soap tablet well you know
something that the private could also do
one themselves Federation absolutely but
right now they're not they don't want to
because that's their edge so eventually
we're gonna have we're already having
the problem that all the boxes that
Amazon delivers in can't go through the
landfills
right because there's so much cardboard
going through the recycling system now
something slightly differently they're
they're centralizing some of this
delivery stuff they have these lockers
at Whole Foods right yeah I mean but it
yeah it's just it's really but there
could be all kinds of things that we
could do there are so many creative
things that we could do to solve this so
I could offer to pick up your groceries
when I'm there and you've sent in your
delivery and I'm going there anyway and
I you live next door you know there's
all kinds of things we could do well you
could we are simulation
vehicle simulation point of vehicle the
Bay Area is blessed with a with a port a
crappy transit system yeah so how do you
how do you interpret that likewise the
LA basin I guess okay but but the
developing urban areas around the world
are new market right this is just the
beginning so how do you interface this
kind of assist of this kind of
simulation system with with transepts
right well transit we can put on the
buses we can put on her yeah right but I
mean that's it's it's to the next
generation we're not there yet we're
just this is amazing that we can do this
right we kind of only do this because we
are working at Lawrence Berkeley labs so
how would you characterize not including
not including fixed transit fixed-line
transit in this model with respect to
your optimization goals there are all
kinds of optimizations here right one is
you want to take people off the roadway
right now we're just looking at the
roadway right we have to validate that
with what we know about what's going on
the roadway we have to add transit buses
in here we are not yet looking at the
transport of humans we are only looking
at the simulation of vehicles on the
roadway right now but this is a
three-month-old project a lot to do
question back on the the veracity set of
issues in those diagrams with the dots
is it ever or mostly the case that a dot
is an individual device yes could you
not then use an IMU I mean that back to
two questions and they're both kind of
in the experimental rather than that
simulations like would it be possible to
use an eye on you then - particularly
locate dated that you could then recover
from the data that the provider gives
you you could Co locate a device and an
IMU knowing that that data would go
through whoever the carriers and come
back up the other side mm-hmm you could
use that to air correct yes that in fact
was when I showed you the map matching
part that's what we were trying to do
because that was a IMU and a cell phone
in the same device so could you repeat
that technique across carriers in order
- yes if we could get that kind of data
but you just need an eye on you and a
cell phone right yeah yeah it sounds
simple but get that data at scale the
other end possibly more questionable
experimental technique would be to
potentially provide an incentive in the
real world and then you know be able to
test both the modeling and you know
potential gains I understand in India
for instance they do synchronized
release of employees from different
factories yes right dazzl we shouldn't
be doing that like you could not only do
it but you might know where to do it and
then you
you measure back whether or not that
worked right right but we're not doing
any of that yet by night yeah so I have
to finish up in two minutes so I'm just
gonna finish up this is an example of
what the data that's being collected
this is 19 million points per day this
is part of that project that we're
trying to get started so this is for all
of LA metro I just go really quick one
thing that we need to think about is
should we be doing you know can we can
we use technology to get people off the
road can we send one person with some
virtual glasses to do the job of three
so we need to start rethinking how we
move people around and when you start
looking at data so that people that are
doing sales forecasting and they're like
they don't have to go travel to
everybody in the United States where you
can have meetings in virtual so I just
want to conclude here I think that the
technology is moving faster than our
social systems can handle right now
or our social systems are handling right
now we need to quickly solve the
increasing stress on our cities
urbanizing is happening we made better
sophistication in our tools to control
it I haven't even talked about policy
these folks are making big decisions
right now right that the city of the
state of California has just approved
driverless cars on the freeway assuming
that they can have a that they have a
remote control which is really spooky
and here's the tweet by somebody that's
a boy now I can be stuck on the highway
with a bunch of empty cars right so we
haven't even talked about that issue and
we haven't we started to talk about this
this is a huge problem so I'll leave you
with the idea are we thinking through
the very hard questions relate
to the pace of the technology and the
impact on our social and economic health
and for the machine learning people in
the room we have to consider how brittle
the technologies are that we are
deploying and pitch for I Triple E
conference in Maui in November we're
going to have a large-scale computing
for transportation studies if you're
interested can we attend virtually no
I'm not sure so this is all fantastic or
you know fairly well-off people who can
afford a Volvo with these you know
wonderful things and who have jobs to
you know go to when when they feel like
it yes but you know I live in southeast
Michigan not too far from Detroit kiss
whose you know public transportation
system sucks
I live there for you you know all of
this technology is is fantastic to move
you know excuse me wealthy white people
in the Bay Area from there nice jobs but
it doesn't tell the people where I live
I totally agree with you that's why I'm
saying that technology is moving way
faster than the social thinking that
goes with it the buses in Detroit the
ambulances on the fire trucks and turn
on some street lights in in Detroit it
would be you know technology do that
then then you know put right and the
whole time a story is it's gonna it's
going to improve accessibility but it
doesn't you know uber and lyft drivers
don't go to the bad neighborhoods right
[Laughter]
yeah and we haven't even talked about
emissions and the neighborhoods that are
around the concentrations of the
emissions all right
you got it I sadly think that this
reminds me of the very first thing that
I learned about traffic which is they
build a traffic light only after a few
people died and to me it seems like this
will get an edge and will start
affecting things when people complain
enough when people lose money when men
or lives that's going to take the
trigger to implement these things I
totally okay i I just don't see it
happening any other way and that the AV
people are the the people are excited
about navies say it's gonna save lives
because most of the fatal crashes are
because of human error but that might be
true
on that side but how many accidents will
be initiated or created because it's a
Navy nobody thinks about that side what
the edge of that technology is and when
will it crash because a remote control
person sitting in a control system
looking at a vehicle going 70 miles an
hour is not going to be able to switch
context any better than you in the
driver's seat sleeping right this is not
an air traffic control problem
any other questions with respect to
but 15 20 years ago or so telecommuting
was supposed to drop drop traffic
congestion
maybe maybe it made its contribution but
but I'm tempted to sort of categorize it
as a little bit a little bit of techno
hype that that's comparable to baby
techno - yep as opposed to say assisted
vehicle assisted driving great
technology we are in maximum hype cycle
and all of this stuff right now maximum
I have seen work well for solving
problems only when there's a carrot and
a stick associated with it so at at the
lab parking has always been free they
have just started discussing basically
billing us a thousand dollars a year you
want to park your vehicle up there
because they're getting rid of their
building and buildings and getting their
participation in addition to which they
are giving you incentives to telecommute
them and and that's the only way I see
and so I like like I said before I think
that's it's it's gonna be a carrot and a
stick to get us to change the way we
behave because unlike Europeans Jeff
Katharina I do want to be able to say I
ran out of laundry detergent
I'd like it now okay the sad fact might
be that we are living in a momentary
peace of time in which we can do that
and our kids swamp you know and that
could happen in addition to the carrot
and stick you know
yeah incentives are really really
important I think there's also just a
learning curve you know where people
sort of imagine that they know what this
technology you know is getting for the
simple imitation is going to be and I
would offer that one way that I think
certainly around here I don't know about
in Michigan
I hope so though our shared lights right
because that that is a collective we
operated you know transportation system
and in my neighborhood people are
getting used to the the fact that there
could be a random byte someplace right
those things and again yeah it's a
myriad of solutions because that doesn't
solve the young mother with the three
children problem and the bad
neighborhood bikes are a solution I'm
saying that it's a piece of the puzzle
[Laughter]
there's a learning learning or this type
of thing at all and that shared bites
are a baby example of that whereby
people can see some of the pros and cons
in some places in the world it's
commonplace over here and that's one of
the reason is I had that three bubbles
is that we've got people technology and
social systems those things are all
getting integrated night now and we're
at the very first part of it and we've
got a technology curve that's going
crazy all right let's think chain again
on all the good questions I don't see